hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to anxiety lost night now my
voice isn't still 100 percent correct
but it's good enough to start recording
and I've got a whole slew of any horror
games for you guys to explore and we're
back in the old recording room the place
where it all began
well I mean not this room specifically I
started out in my mom's basement just
downstairs but uh I moved up to this
room and then then started making videos
but this is anxiety last night and there
was a game that came before it called
anxiety that I believe was another
horror game that's like this kind of 2d
style everything is going to be alright
just need to calm down and drive it's
okay just a little bit more what no not
again not now okay so in this one [ __ ]
come on in this one I believe you're
trapped in a car and death lurks around
every corner
oh I'm little chittim Utley trapped in
the car why am I sitting in the middle
why am I in the absolute middle of this
it's dark outside yeah I'm aware
oh that's not a good thing hey hey all
you monsters I'm here okay there should
be a bus station oh boy hi sorry about
all the honking I need a map I need a
map well that doesn't work okay alright
let's look at that there's one not far
from here ye you national parks bring
nature to your soul I should be able to
walk there I have to go outside yeah
that's probably a man
Hey oh it's a monster I summoned with my
honking the Cougar Oh doh a Cougars out
there alrighty then
hey hey cougar oh boy that's not good
oh no oh I've done goofed ammonite ok
OOP hello I need a key
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that one up oh [ __ ] I did
it
alright so that's not working I didn't
save his number whose number are you
talking about here I should have his
business card somewhere were you talking
about
hi okay hang on hang on a second why do
I keep this good alright so there may be
a piece of the puzzle missing from the
first game I might go back and play that
later so I yeah well these are these are
not reassuring noises so he gave me a
business card yeah somewhere gr garage
Auto Works okay so I got his number
sorry right I'm about to die it's me
don't you recognize my voice
uh death lurks around the corner car
won't start need you help please pretty
please
I don't know North route of the National
Park you know where all the demons are
where they're gonna come kill me oh [ __ ]
just shut up and help me please
that would be lovely an hour I'm gonna
be dead in an hour I can't stop honking
my horn can't wait that long just walk
me through it what should I do
okay clearly I don't remember
yeesh alrighty then
ok gonna do that you gave me a note
where is it a note what do you mean a
note put in my bag oh look
ok got it I looks awful
Lisa Madison alrighty then yeah I don't
remember why did I leave this Oh God
why do I have that why do I have that
alright got a key it's okay it's okay
alright
am I gonna die oh hi ha ha ha ah you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
y'all y'all oh boy
man my voice is not gonna survive this
hi hello ok
oh boy turn off air conditioner every
lighting car wiper unplug your radio
power cable processing pressing the horn
also makes it worse oops my bad
ok remember don't turn on all devices in
one time make sure all electronic
devices are off when you start the
ignition ok alrighty then
meep-meep okay sorry
shouldn't meep I get it no meeping hmmm
I don't need this anymore oh I'm gonna
be like Fran bow ok so take this why is
it bloody why is everything I own bloody
and why is there just a normal garage
guy going about his business alright
ooba-dooba do blink got that turn off
the lights
mm do it alright do did that do did that
didn't know so complex to turn off my
goddamn stuff happy to do that okay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
well that's not what I wanted
yeah all right bye calm down here all
right so I need to turn off no not that
god damn it okay is everything off [ __ ]
hi here we go back okay so I got a son
[ __ ] stop okay enough II [ __ ] off all
right so I got a turn off oh maybe maybe
that got turned on again hey ty okay
well that's that's not supposed to be on
okay let's let's try this I followed the
instructions okay unplug pressing horn
makes worse lights on oh my oh I know
what's up my these are on ah there we go
okay BAM
hi stop that please can I just turn out
there go away okay I don't want it okay
all right then god damn it how did these
get turned on
I [ __ ] God oh yeah alrighty then
alright I get it I get it I get into
some kind of this some electron Oh put
the [ __ ] Mami's my [ __ ] off I get it I
get it I get it
stop you're trying to do me a great
goofin hello
I know I get it stop what now thank you
oh [ __ ] off god dammit I was that close
I'd [ __ ] me it [ __ ] me oh okay alright
that's that's nice that's real nice
that's real nice ye alrighty then
we got no attacker on the way I probably
spoke too soon but whatever
yay it's not my fault I was that close
to winning and then I died it's not my
fault I deserve a better life I don't
know you got a bloody rope
you got a bloody screwdriver you got a
lot of benzodiazepine you [ __ ] I don't
know I don't exactly know what's coming
[ __ ] hell oh is that okay
whoo oh boy thousand okay
alright so that was anxiety last night
pretty good start to the slew of horror
games but I've got a big list
I've got like 30 games to get through
but my voice may not keep up through it
all but I will try my best to get you
all the horror games you can possibly
imagine along with some old favorites I
got subnautica coming at you real soon
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next videos bye bye